so let's uh talk about the spectacular
pictures today of scotland's last
coal-fired power station being
demolished and coal is very close to
complete extinction in fact in the uk
but this country like most others
continues to rely on other fossil fuels
mainly oil and gas for energy
but there's pressure to reduce that in a
bid to cut emissions and slow climate
change
and this week's the uk's oil and gas
strategy was challenged in court by
campaigners and richard what was this
court case all about and is litigation
generally likely to have some sort of
influence on on speeding up our
transition towards renewables do you
think
yes this court case was brought by a
group called paid to pollute and the
basis of their case is that basically if
you look at the way that um the oil gas
industry intersects with the treasury
some years it ends up paying paying tax
net to the treasury other years it ends
up taking tax net from the treasury
so the plaintiffs in this case are
basically organ
arguing that in the years when it
actually receives money this is a
perverse incentive effectively it's
paying oil companies to get stuff out of
the ground but the very time when
scientists and
various other analyses are basically
saying we shouldn't be getting so much
oil and gas out of the ground in fact we
shouldn't be doing any more exploration
and development if we are just to have
you know enough fossil fuels that can
keep us but over 1.5 celsius limit so
they had the hearing yesterday and we
should be getting a judgment maybe
tomorrow maybe maybe in a week or two
and richard briefly i mean there's court
cases around the world are they making a
difference to government policies
i think some have made a big difference
the big one was the agenda co-op case
brought against the dutch government a
couple of years back which actually
really forced the government to
accelerate its carbon cutting
uh pledges but often the court cases
raise publicity about an issue and that
can be as useful in the long run as
actually winning and that i think is
probably the case with this paid to
pollute one that we're seeing you know
the subsidy regime is quite murky and
this will will i think you know shine
some light upon it
cece what do you think do you think that
this is basically down to governments
making decisions about transitioning
away from fossil fuels or can other
influences
be important like public pressure for
example
yeah i think these cases are perfect
demonstration of people power right i
think people power are um can be very
strong and effective but the challenge
that we face is um how can we scale
people power i think um basically we
don't just want one successful case or
two successful cases we want lots of
cases and lots of individual actions and
um the the trouble with that is that you
know um it's hard to scale people power
um but i think one of the key issues
that we need to address in in this
challenge is that we need to really make
this mental linkage between climate
change which is a very abstract uh
concept with individual lives and you
know how does climate change reduce food
on your tables how does climate change
stop your children from going to school
once every individual has made that
mental link i mean i struggle with it
sometimes too um even after studying
climate change for so many years um once
people have made that mental link
between that abstract concept um and
their daily lives then they can make
really individual changes they can all
be their organizations they can lobby
their workplaces they can lobby their
governments okay um so i think that's
okay
sorry to cut you off cece but just a
quick word on on that issue with richard
because the government might say well
well yes but we need to worry about
energy security that relates to people
they might worry about getting a steady
supply of electricity people in the
fossil fuel industry will worry about
their jobs i mean people can relate to
that too the transition has to be
managed carefully doesn't it
yes it does and we've seen examples of
course in the uk of how not to do it
with the phase out of cold mining uh
going back several decades that was a
really disruptive and and very unfair
transition germany chile other countries
are moving off of coal via other routes
basically consultations with mining
communities working out what support
they need in order to get through this
but i think it's also it's also
important to look at the overall scale
of likely job losses if you compare the
size of the workforce in the uk oil and
gas industry for example it's nothing
compared with a number of workers in
retail who've lost their jobs over the
last 10 20 years as online retailing has
become a thing so yes let's have a
transition and a just transition but
actually really let's make it a genuine
transition